so hearing that voice that says whatever
and you can you can go to therapy for
yours you can identify who that voice
was you can find all was the third grade
teacher and she used to tell me this all
the time and I still here now whatever
we can we can all rationalize who that
might be but when you're in that moment
and let's suppose you don't have another
amazing actor who's confiding in you how
would you advise or maybe you can only
tell your own process and that's fine to
get rid of that voice because I think
everybody hears it whatever just
stepping out the front door did it go to
the grocery store you know we can't it's
there's no magic pill except to just
take contrary action take an action
that's contrary to what you're hearing
in your head or to what you might be
feeling because what I was feeling there
you know with being you know I'm afraid
they're going to find out that I'm a
fraud and they're going to fire me and
none of that had any relation to reality
that's just my own self doubt and it's
not real it has no relationship to
reality whatsoever and so I did you know
you have to just then put one foot in
front of the other and continue moving
forward in a positive way taking actions
that are contrary to those feelings
directly contrary to those feelings you
know if you're feeling self-doubt act
with confidence and and that's how I get
through it then it still happens it
still happens but that's exactly how I
get through it I I was in a miniseries a
couple of weeks ago that ended a couple
of weeks ago on IFC another will ferrell
project called the spoils of Babylon and
my scenes were with val kilmer we played
a couple of army generals and we were
doing some green screen work in a in an
old car driving down a road after we had
just killed someone and the director
Matt Piedmont said all right now in this
tech I want you guys to pull over to the
side of the road
and Steve I want you to tell Val but you
you've fallen in love with him ok button
and that was my director on front of
your die presents and I got to know him
pretty well and I really trust him and
even though it I thought well this is a
little odd ok we're going to go for it
and you know what we just went for it
Val and I both just went for it and it
was one of those things where you just
had to fully commit to it and make a
decision to do it and so that's what we
did and we had quite a torrid love scene
in the front seat of that car most of
which did not make it into the into the
miniseries but we committed to it we
went for it there weren't any tongues
but yeah and so yeah I mean for the
point is you have to you have to commit
and act as if that's not what you're
feeling and take that contrary action if
you're if you're feeling self doubt or
apprehension or fear the only way
through it is through it but you have to
move forward through it
you